(upbeat music)
- Where on Earth
is Dana and Julia?
- No guys will ever love you,
because you're fugly biatches!
Get out!
(bodies thud on the floor)
- Eh!
- [Bathroom Girls] Biatches!
- Ham bump!
- I don't understand
why we're both so ugly.
- If I stay this ugly, no guy is
ever gonna wanna tap my asshole.
Oh my god, Ms. Klitnick
slept over for the
first time last night.
I heard her and my dad doing it.
- Cool, what kind of noises?
- It sounded like they were
beating a moose to death.
Ooooh, moomoo!
- Eww, your breath smells.
- Listen, I have a secret
and it has to do with sex.
- Oh my god, yes!
- I stole this from
my dad's horny drawer.
I heard the pharmacist
call it boner juice.
It's supposed to make guys
fall in love with you.
(door squeaks)
- Oosh oosh!
Pump your horny jam.
Pump you up, gonna
make you horny.
(door slams)
(flatulates)
- Hot Hairy Croatian
is so horny.
- He's so horny!
Let's go, we're
about to become the
most hottest girls in our class.
(flatulates)
- Oosh.
- Oh me oh my ad-oh-nye!
Special class lunch today.
My homemade sweet beef tips.
Ms. Klitnick is so
happy today, children.
I'm in love, with Govindas
Goodman, Dana's father.
- Dude, your dad
fucked Klitnick.
(flesh slaps)
- Distract everyone.
(bag crinkles)
(underwear whooshes
across the room)
- Look what just flew in here.
- Ooh!
Mmm.
Oh my.
Fly away bird, ooh nasty.
Let's eat!
(chairs squeak)
- Hold on to your bush, we're
about to become popular.
(food crunches)
- Ow!
You just hit me, what is that?
- Oh it hurts, it hurts!
It feels good!
Ah, ah, ah!
- Uh!
Get some!
Uh!
- Oy no!
- Get your dick off my dick man!
- Tu eres mas feo
que culo de un mono.
(imitates motor)
- This feels so awesome!
- Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
I'm having an angina attack.
Hide my bong and my rolling
papers on my boobie.
Ow!
- [Students] Ah, ah.
(bodies thud)
(vomits)
(fire alarm rings)
(sprinklers rain down)
- Oy!
- Oh shit.
- Ms. Klitnick,
look what I found.
Dana's dad's name is on it.
- Oh my gosh, Govindas.
I didn't, I thought, my body.
(bottle rattles)
(Ms. Klitnick cries)
(boy whooshes through window)
(engine starts)
- I love my titties
in the breeze!
- Dana and Julia!
Get on the naughty
carpet right now!
(phone beeps)
(phone rings)
- [Govindas's
Voicemail] Namaste.
You've reached Govindas Goodman.
Please leave a
message for myself
or the Yoga and Breast
Center Shala at the gong.
Rom rom ohm, gong!
- Shalom, Govindas, it's Dottie.
Dana poured your erection
medication in my kosher tips.
Everyone got ill and
my heart is broken.
I thought we had natural
chemistry last night.
I feel so betrayed, I
feel so unattractive.
I don't know how we're
gonna salvage this.
Shalom!
(kissing noises)
- Guys like us!
- Breast day ever!
- [Male Student] Muy bueno!
- Ham bump!
(upbeat music)